Washington Post reports that Germany is
perplexed as president Trump escalates
his feud with Berlin tensions emerge
between mr. Trump and Chancellor Angela
Merkel during his overseas trip last
week after the g7 and NATO meetings
Merkel said that Europe could no longer
rely on others
apparently meaning the United States
while President Trump escalated that
feud yesterday by tweeting quote we have
a massive trade deficit with Germany
very bad for us this will change Merkel
tried to ease the dispute yesterday by
saying transatlantic relations are of
paramount importance
Lionel Barbour is the editor of the
Financial Times and we're pleased to
have him with us this morning Lionel
good morning morning Charlie again with
what the report and the news report that
President Trump is plans to withdraw
from the Paris agreement what are the
implications of that for the United
States for the world and for Europe if
President Trump indeed is going to pull
out of the Paris Accords which remember
this treaty was ratified it's been
backed by the major countries including
China and India as well as the Europeans
this is a big move this is America first
in caps and it's not going to go down
well amongst allies they will look at
America and say why are you pulling out
when big business companies like Exxon
is backing the deal will it simply be
seen as abdicating leadership in the
world well it's not just advocating
leadership it's actually just going
unilateral and pulling yourself out when
other countries the big polluters
countries like I mean particularly
important China actually signed up so
why storm out of the tent I don't we
don't get it Mike and India as well
signed up as well one of the great
polluters and the idea that that climate
change is a threat to US national
security
well climate change it is still disputed
among scientists but on balance given
the risk you'd say why not why take the
risk of not trying to do something to
tackle it remember more than 20 years
ago George Bush refused to sign the
Kyoto Accord again but that Accord did
not include China and second the Senate
was massively against more than 95 votes
this is not the case today
there was a big consensus behind Paris
was its enhanced China's leadership
minute of China's well if you put it on
top of the trans-pacific partnership
which again Donald Trump present Trump
pulled out of that again seeds the
ground to China and that's going to
worry a lot of people not just in Europe
but also in Asia I'm struck by your
comments about America first in caps
because Trump administration officials
have said America first does not mean
America alone what message do you think
this sends though well it will be
America alone because nobody else of any
significance intends to pull out of
these of the Paris treaty there may be
even some questions about sanctions
we'll have to see that because remember
America signed up to this deal I think
more important you have to look at the
way mr. Trump and many people in his
administration look at foreign policy
it's a zero-sum game it's purely
transactional we don't want to do
anything multilateral or anything that
Barack Obama did is we're not going to
do it we're going to one pick the
problem with that if you go purely
bilateral what kind of signal does that
send to big players like Russia and
China if it's just a zero-sum world and
what about the tension emerging now
between the United States and Germany
well I think here I would say that
President Trump does have some important
points Germany's current account surplus
is way too high
it's got 50 billion that's a trade
surplus with the United States
similarly Germany is not committing
enough money to the NATO alliance but
the way he's going about it
I would argue particularly given a
German general election campaign is
totally counterproductive but you've
also said to me last night on a PBS
program that you think the President
Trump by the actions he took in Europe
and what he said in Europe and what he's
doing now reportedly will unite Europe I
think those are great many commentators
thought that last year when we had
brexit and then Donald Trump's victory
that this would be like a populist virus
spreading throughout Europe and you'd
see the beginnings at the end of the
European Union actually what's happened
it's not a virus it's an antidote you
Europeans actually getting closer on the
back of Emmanuel macron victory in
France I think in the next few months
and the more America appears to be going
alone then you will see greater European
unity we don't want to build a Europe
against America but America is forcing
Europe to unify alright you know
Margaret to see more to come for sure
thank you very much for joining us this
morning